all right I have to start by saying I
bring my own biases and assumptions to
this discussion so um and no pun
intended on that
um
for my biases I'm all in on the rapid
pace of innovation uh in AI
um by the time I'm done with this talk
there's been probably a dozen more white
papers for deep learning
it's dizzying
um I can't keep up and I'm a
practitioner I like to call myself one
um that said I'm also acutely aware of
the social technical issues where
um
you know there isn't enough governance
uh in in what we do or I would assume
some of you are trying to do how many
people here are in the field of machine
learning whether it's deep learning or
there you go
um
all right so for I said biases and
assumptions so I guess I owe you
assumptions assumptions I assume that
everyone in this talk
at least understands what AI is
um if not I can give a quick primer
um
and I'm going to be talking about the
Deep learning application of machine
learning here today uh and in a weird
way this is a kind of unconventional
talk I'm going to start with a story
it's 2004 I'm
working for the then Office of the
governor in Richmond Virginia that's
this beautiful picture you're seeing
here
um I did not take this picture I do not
know who to attribute it to it's lovely
um
I finished work
change out of my workloads
get my gym clothes on and start my half
mile track walk between the Capitol
building and my gym
city right so lots of one-lane Roads
I'm crossing got my headphones on uh two
patrol cars come in like hot like full
force block my path
guns drawn I'm like freaking out because
all I wanted to do was some squats
um and so I squatted got on the floor
even before they said something or maybe
they've been yelling at it because I had
my headphones in
you know the story
knee on my back hand stretched out
case of
um
it was a case of uh
I was wrongly identified essentially
mistaken identity that's the that's the
term
so it's a I guess it's it was from from
uh flesh-based API standpoint it was
sort of a low accuracy low Precision or
recall from from uh the police officers
there and I fit the description of an
apparent criminal I was wearing sweats
gray sweats and a white tee which in
2004 probably described half of Richmond
males
um there's a point to that story I was
traumatized I still am uh but thankfully
nothing bad happened I'm here right uh
they let me go and so who am I I'm noble
noble Akerson
I'm the one in the middle in case it was
hard
to tell I'm fortunate to call myself a
father to those two wonderful girls you
see for work I'm a product executive at
a company that you may not have heard of
called venterra Corporation
it's a northern Virginia
I focus on the responsible delivery
maintenance uh and use of artificial
intelligence systems
and as you may know working with some of
these non-deterministic systems like
machine learning is super hard so if
you're stuck somewhere and you need help
especially with responsible Ai and some
of these topics that we're going to talk
about today I'm probably the easiest
person to find on social media and I
probably posted my socials around here
somewhere on some one of the or two of
these slides
so again responsible AI That's that term
um
why do I work in responsible AI I worked
so that my daughters
can live in a world that is more
Equitable and fair with a software that
is going to become monitor is already
commodified right now
um I work in this space because
you know actually let me ask you a
question what was your time to AI this
morning
okay I'll ask it a different way
from the moment you were dead asleep
to waking up when do you think you
started interacting with an AI
pick up your phone
all right so if AI is to be ambient it
better be fair and I want to be a good
ancestor I want all of us to be good
ancestors for the systems intelligence
systems that we build I'm very excited
to be here at Strangelove to talk about
Fairless fairness and bias uh one of the
five pillars of responsible development
and use of AI and with that let's talk
about those pillars
um responsible AI
what responsible AI means in practice is
that on any given day I'm leading my
teams to Leverage human-centered in a
machine learning approaches and
practices like how to teach an AI to
accept uh user feedback or process it
and to have that part of uh you know
improving a model to make things better
for us we call that
mlux I've heard being called
human-centered ml
very nascent practice
I'm also helping teams
and take this annoying thing right there
off I'm also helping teams Define what
fairness means for their machine
learning use cases and to de-bias uh
learned models as best as we can
I'm implementing human interpretable
models that are complete accurate and
meaningful as well as consistent
explanations across
equivalent models for example we you
sometimes hear that called
explainability or xai
last time I was here at strange loop I
gave you a lens into designing and
delivering privacy preserve preserving
machine learning capabilities uh
inherited from your data and AI
governance practices and policies and at
this rate I need to come back here for
maybe two more of these types of talks
to round it out with all the all the
five today you get a twofer actually and
then the last one is more security and
robustness
where we're designing things that are
secure and robust uh and and can't be
taken over by adversarial actors for
example
uh so again you get a two for today I'm
going to be talking about both
bias and uh explaining why uh of you
know why a machine learning model is
predicting what it what it is doing
because you know you can't change you
can't improve or or de-bias without
understanding what's going on with a
traditional Black Box model
so let's get started
so I asked that question you know your
time to Ai and I got chirps and I said
you know if AI is to be ambient it
better be fair if it took it kind of
took a few seconds for some of you to
figure out what was my time to AI this
morning
um
and if it took a few seconds to figure
out uh which features on say your phone
Power was powered by AI then perhaps the
value it delivers
caves fairly at least it behaves well
right do we agree with that statement
um that said throughout your day you may
have interactions
where you may need more context on why a
recommendation was made or why you on
the flight here to strange Loop perhaps
you were flagged as a suspicious
Traveler
that has happened to me
many times
but I get no explanations
I don't understand it's black box
maybe someone behind the curtain might
understand but not me as a consumer
machine learning teams want to know this
as well like the lens
into an inputs effects on a prediction
also
you know your legal team wants wanting
to know especially when things blow up
um you know if it's on the internet
something inevitable is going to happen
and your legal team may want to sort of
clean up the mess or if you're really
unlucky Regulators might come knocking
you need to explain that we'll get into
that
which brings us to
bias and fairness like how do you
assess what fairness means
um
it's a tough question and there's no
single definition actually there's no
case law in the United States that has a
single definition of fairness which
makes this talk useless I'm sorry we'll
keep going no saying
um when we talk about fairness though
we're talking about individual fairness
in a broader sense uh seeks for similar
individuals to be treated well similarly
when we talk about group fairness and
it's brought a sense
it segments populations into groups
defined by what we call protected
attributes or protected classes legally
protected classes uh at least in the
United States and looks for some
statistical measure to be equal across
those groups
in theory it works but in practice it's
kind of tough
common applications of fairness Falls in
healthcare
a human Capital Management so if you've
ever read anything on the internet
you've probably heard about Compass
something about reciditism uh people you
know
automated decisions to make sure someone
uh won't reoffend and go back to jail
that kind of stuff I promise I'll spare
you those examples because you can
always Google those
um
law enforcement is a big one right
um predictive policing which
justice department uh trying to find
trying to prepare for this talk I'm like
how many predictive policing startups
are actually being implemented by local
law enforcement and there's a a paper on
this where justice department admits
they don't really know how many predpoll
AI products they've actually funded
which is kind of scary
um
fairness is hard uh it um you know you
can't it's hard to mathematically
quantify and so a lot of researchers
have done the grunt work of
um creating some baseline
metrics that we'll go over today as well
we want to do our best to have ai act as
fairly as possible
not just for social technical reasons
but it's just good business right think
of
uh if you're familiar with a typical
machine learning workflow one of the
final steps once you've served a learned
model into production uh is to monitor
for drift or skew
I'm gonna go on a leap and I'm going to
just say here and some of you
practitioners and academics in the crowd
are probably going to you know pull me
aside and tell me I'm wrong
but bias is a form of skew
it's noise and when you're trying to run
a business you do not want noise it's
just bad business
um so it affects your quality of service
you want to treat people well you do you
want to sort of scale again good
business you want as many people to use
your product adopt your product so you
can get your magical product Market fit
you can't do that if you're excluding or
you're treating people unfairly
unintentionally
and that is this concept of traumatized
data eye credit that phrase It's kind of
dramatic but I credit that phrase to one
Nicole Turner lead she's at she's a
wonderful sister out in DC uh she works
at Brookings Institute she and she talks
about how trauma in the sense of
collective
psychological emotional and cognitive
distress experienced by an unprivileged
Class A group such as African Americans
affects the AI models we use
so these are popular of these are a few
popular metrics we use to measure
fairness in the same way
you would assess say the sex the success
of your model using a confusion Matrix
this is a screenshot from
[Music]
IBM's IBM research and this is some of
the the I think there are a few more
metrics that you use to guide what fair
means uh for your context
uh if you want to take a second and are
very interested I'll make these slides
available uh for you as well
all right
I wish I had some water
do we feel humans are perfect
it's a leading question loaded
um humans aren't perfect right
we I feel we encode or better yet
propagate
our biases in the data we use to train
AI
I'll give one example with historical
bias you know tying that back into the
point of that Richmond Virginia story
where the cops pinned me down mistaken
identity thing
police as I hinted at
departments use algorithms to help
figure out where to send resources
it's very hard to find numbers on how
many police departments do
however machine learning algorithms
today
are all are mostly all correlative right
they're not causal
the algorithm doesn't understand if an
arrest
um was unfair or unjust it just sees an
arrest
you're a saint and a scholar sir thank
you
he just sees an arrest
and the algorithm is going to send
police
to where it thinks the crime is
but on its own it won't understand that
traditionally this is where police have
sent resources
for example
neighborhoods
where a lot of people look like me
therefore that's where the AI sees the
crime
therefore
that's where the police
see the crime
in some cases egregiously unfairly
like two African-American Brothers just
sitting at a Starbucks
and getting arrested only to be
released and Starbucks sent releasing
this apology
therefore that's where they've made
arrests
therefore more resources are sent there
fore the data that we have access to is
traumatized and the output of a machine
learning algorithm leads to more
Prejudice assumptions stereotypes based
assumptions leading to new harms amongst
groups or individuals
it is the worst
flywheel
one can ever imagine
seriously um they're startups Clear View
I'm sorry does anybody work for
Clearview here
I can talk [ __ ] about them okay
um
clear they're companies they're startups
out there thinking they've cracked
precognition from Minority Report it's
pretty scary
bias is a way to shortcut decision
making at a subconscious level I'm not
talking about statistical bias I'm just
talking about bias
um it's human
but it's reflected in the data that we
collect
right
there so these are the types of bias
there this is from a Cornell University
paper
yeah I'm using the social technical
angle to make a point and also to
intentionally make you uncomfortable if
you are or just to drive the point home
but know that these techniques and tools
that I'm talking about
can be applied to frankly any group of
things
right think about it Netflix or Amazon
recommender systems for example
they suffer a lot from popularity bias
do you know how many things you might
have missed
um because of what was pushed in front
of you
it also leads to harm think about it
your social media feed that filter
bubble we keep hearing about
and misinformation disinformation or
malinformation being sort of subverted
to systems being subverted
bias starts in the data
the algorithms transmitted
and the users
are susceptible to harm because the
outcomes don't reflect the world we like
to live in
because
deep learning applications machine
learning applications generally one are
causal obviously our correlative not
causal
they're also non-deterministic
we bias
the inputs
we need to uh bias the inputs to get the
desired results
um for the well we biased the inputs or
outputs whether you're pre-processing or
post-processing in order to get the
desired results that we want to and
those familiar with like deep learning
neural networks for example we include
Randomness right we include weights we
include biases
to each neuron on purpose so that a
neuron can fire for example
similarly we apply algorithms
um during pre-processing
during pre-training uh sorry
pre-processing during in processing so
like while you're training
and then of course on the labels or on
the prediction itself post-processing
phase
to provide uh our desired definition of
fare
because with deep learning there's no
guarantee that that provided input will
provide exactly the same or expected
output we need to scrutinize and and
have the systems that I'll go over here
in a second don't worry there's going to
be techy stuff
um
yeah uh we we want to make sure we don't
uh harm people essentially
in the next
30 years or maybe less than that 20 or
so minutes
I hope you take away that fairness and
bias is hard so that yes when Facebook
chatbot goes Rogue know that they're
humans behind that and no Facebook as a
monolith is not racist
these are hard problems
these are hard problems that affect
consumers you and I
um they affect the data scientists and
engineers in the room
they affect policy and uh stakeholders
and this entire talk is framed around
these three stakeholders but because
I've already put you to sleep I'm going
to start with policy
all right so for policy you want to
increase trust
with policy makers you want to reduce
scrutiny and you want to innovate
you want to show that you're being good
stewards
and if something happens you're able to
explain it
uh and have certain uh policies
internally to sort of catalog or report
against things that may be going right
or things that are going wrong
so you increase trust by simply being
responsible uh in the development the
delivery and advocating for and
listening in for the responsible use of
the systems that you build
getting regulatory eyes off your company
leaves you to innovate
I mean that's not a controversial
statement right if you're doing a good
thing and you have a brand trust for
being good stewards of users data
yeah you know you'll see
Congress parade Google Facebook and
somehow Tim Cook or Tim apple is not uh
in front of Congress sometimes he is
um
I think they're doing
um ads now in Apple news
um
it builds Data Trust uh in your
customers as long as you're responsible
in the delivery of the systems and your
delivering good value right it's just
ambient
the AI is working for you and you wake
up and by noon you've used like 70 000
AIS and you have no idea
it's just obvious good business sense
um
I'm gonna use one of those examples that
I promised I wouldn't use but this is
important to make another point
so Amazon a few years ago
decided to roll out
same day delivery and yes Amazon with
all the phds and talent
makes mistakes
they can afford to make mistakes
if you're a startup maybe you can't
um
they have an army and infantry of
attorneys and so stop me if you heard
this one
Amazon chooses six maybe more this is
what was in the paper companies uh sort
of cities to roll out same day delivery
the blue was where they decided their AI
decided to provide coverage the gray
was where they decided to not cover
in the initial rollout
Roxbury if we look at Boston Township
was excluded
you know where this is going
eerily similar to redlining Maps
um where lenders had identified Roxbury
as hazardous
but to Amazon they still got fined
because failure of fairness through
unawareness
is no excuse
perhaps Amazon was just predicting the
number of purchases Amazon's not racist
the Amazon's not a thing or person right
people come into work every day trying
to do good by you and I
they were just predicting the number of
purchases the AI was trained to
unfortunately the number of purchases in
a given Locale correlates with affluence
still good
which correlates with in some cases race
and in the U.S
race is a protected legal class
Amazon almost certainly did not look at
a customer's race when they built this
product it's called proxy effects
secondary effects
so you know Congress comes running how
does Amazon then explain to Regulators I
promise we're not racist
I remember I promised you a twofer I'm
gonna talk take a tangent talk about
explainability
Regulators are increasingly requiring
model explanations when things go wrong
with deployed models
simple models are often inherently
interpretable but as models become
complex there's example deep learning
examples or ensembles of models
being transparent trying to understand
what's happening becomes a little bit
more difficult traditionally
uh com uh
complex models are often described as
Black Box models all right I don't like
that term but um
but it's opaque we don't know what's
happening and historically we've
accepted it but I'm so glad that since I
started given this talk more and more
ecosystems and platforms are sort of
including ways to explain it so that's
promising
we're transport was transparent uh
models
we look to explain what deep learning
what a deep learning model looks at to
make a classification a recommendation
or a prediction by highlighting feature
importances on an input
again
this is good for explaining it why I got
flagged as a as a consumer why I got
flagged as a um you know problematic
traveler or why you go model is behaving
in a certain way for a data scientist or
explained to Congress
why we left that Roxbury
so we look at certain tools
like
lime
integrated gradients or in this case
shop
stands for shapely additive explanations
I came from Microsoft research I believe
Scott Lumberg at Al I know Scott Lumberg
was one of the the contributors
inventors of this
uh tool it's pretty cool it applies Game
Theory to explain the output of a
machine learning model
shop offers a library of visualization
options so that you can explain which
feature is important which features are
more dominant so we're showing let's say
the mean absolute value uh or the shaft
value of each feature at a global level
in this case of the visual on the right
um
you're looking at something called a
waterfall plot that depicts uh a plot of
the classic Boston Housing data set if
you've ever been on kaggle you probably
looked at that data set to predict uh
house price per a specific locale
in Boston and here we're explaining why
the model made the prediction it made
note that the blue arrows reflect the
lowest impact on a model's prediction uh
where as
um you know
we see the poor areas of us of Boston uh
Drive housing prices they call it LSAT
like the percentage of lower status of a
specific population
using shaft we're looking further than
coefficients of the model we're using
training data to give impact of each of
these features so rooms and taxes crime
per area the age you can see that lstat
um the lower status areas
have the most impact to the features
prediction
so these are some questions to consider
again the the visual you see on the
right here are the in the U.S anyway the
legally protected classes I think
there's some overlap with the EU as well
if you want to do business there these
are some questions that you might want
to ask does our
use case require
um
uh legally protected classes in some
cases yes right your bank you need to
know some the age of your
um your your uh requester of a loan to
give them a loan uh for example so there
are justifications to do that
are there secondary facts could there be
correlative correlatory
um reasons uh why even though I'm not
using
skin color uh that I can infer skin
color through a secondary effect
and you know on my
you know you know harming someone
Adventure essentially it just seems like
an obvious question but a very hard
answer to get to
so that's policy uh again you're trying
to avoid representational harm
um you want to reduce the amplification
of stereotypes in that case you want to
prevent the opportunity denial uh and
frankly my favorite as a product manager
disproportionate product failure because
it just doesn't make good business if
I'm building this and I want to expand
uh excluding folks
the part
that I've Been Told
strange Loop is here for let's talk
about
the machine learning team how we
increase data and model understanding
and create better algorithms and produce
robust models
so here I'm going to sort of show the
typical workflow of a machine learning
um
process
to fight AI bias we introduce a variety
of algorithms to discover where the bias
might be to mitigate bias
for example within a typical machine
learning life cycle you may want to have
a way to understand
Black Box classification of a regression
model right so you might want to do a
counter factual what would happen if
tensorflow has that as part of their tfx
Pipeline and so you can probably run a
what-if analysis on that and and for
different scenarios as to how
um additional data being introduced or
additional models being introduced from
say user feedback could affect your
model
for bias detection and mitigation what
algorithm you use depends on whether you
want to fix
the data itself
call that pre-processing
fix or test against the classifier
or training so in processing and or
um lastly the predictions or the AI
recommendation itself so the
post-processing algorithm right
by pre-processing
we run tests on the data itself like so
say for example if you can modify the
training data like you have access to
the training data then a pre-processing
algorithm
can work there are a few of them
uh re-weighing algorithms I'll provide a
if you're in the slack on on the channel
I'll
just to see how I do with time I might
just start throwing my notebooks and
some of my resources on there I've
already started so make sure you're you
look for this talk in in slack that
Channel or whatever
I dropped part of the demo portion for
this
by end processing we mean the algorithm
oh yeah I didn't realize I did that this
was from last week's talk I gave the
same talk last week so here you go you
can scan that as I talk
by in processing
um
we mean oh by the way the I the security
folks this is I promise not
this goes to IBM's aif360 where a lot of
my research comes from
trust me
by in processing we mean an algorithm to
mitigate buys that is applied to the
model
there we go the model during training on
a classifier so here you if you can
modify the learning algorithm then an
in-processing algorithm such as
adversarial divising or something like
that can be used
and then by post processing uh we mean
we test for bias against a predicted
against predicted labels basically here
we're just messing with uh labels to
address the Harms in an under uh
privilege or a protected class
by the way
this is also typically where you would
try to explain your prediction again in
that evaluation stage of your your
workflow
and you don't have to use shop I like
shop because the visuals are pretty uh
and the algorithms are a little bit more
robust in my opinion there's if you're
doing a lot of images or videos you
might want to use integrated gradients
for example lime is also bundled in a
lot of these
bias mitigation algorithm or the
toolkits or the libraries like aif from
IBM research fairlearn I believe also
uses lime
fairlearn is from Microsoft research
as you would normally do after you've
served in your monitoring your model
um
you know monitoring and debugging again
for me
model SKU is a form sorry bias is a form
of model scheme
another way to look at this and to
internalize this how this fits into the
typical workflow
I want to quickly give a refresher
the process starts with a typical
process of a supervised machine learning
process starts with training your data
set well it doesn't start there but I'm
cutting some Corners which contains a
sequence of instances where each
instance has two components your
features and the correct prediction of
those features are for those features
machine learning algorithm is trained on
this training data set to produce a
machine learning model
a second data set which with features
and correct predictions we call that a
test data set is used to assess the
accuracy of the model
and then a random partitioning of the
random partitioning algorithm I actually
don't know how that works not that deep
is used to split the the initial data
set into training and task data sets
um
bias can enter the system in any of the
three steps
right so let's look at it in action
um
let me see
how are we doing on time it's 11 30. I
have until
I'm gonna put this notebook I'm gonna
flag this part and I'm going to put this
notebook on our um
uh slack Channel just to save time is
that okay
all right let me do that
let me do that instead
all right
so I've been looking at some of you guys
as I talk and
I can spot folks that do this day in and
day out
I have to admit I call myself a
practitioner
I lead teams on the federal side and
then on the commercial side at my
company so I'm not building I don't
model fit uh every day
uh so I'm seeing some of you who are
rolling your eyes it's like there's a
trade-off there's a catch
between optimizing for bias because
something's got to give you're gonna if
you optimize for bias you sacrifice
performance
and you can also sacrifice accuracy
it's like a squeeze toy right one
impacts the other
in a typical machine learning objective
you want to solve an optimization
problem
right
the goal is to minimize the error
in order to get to fairness our our
objective is to solve a constrained
optimization problem so there's a
tension there
it's actually why my team hates it when
I come in with all the ethics talk
right because they just want to get it
out
get the product out
so rather than say I'll give an example
of what I'm trying to say it's like
find if I say like find the model in my
class that minimizes the error
rather than saying that you'll say find
the model in my class that minimizes the
error subject to the constraint that
none of these
say seven racial categories or whatever
the protected attribute you want to
solve for should have a false negative
rate more than say one percent
different than the other ones and it
comes that but that might sound like a
mouthful all I'm trying to say comes
down to this
from what we've learned from our model
is there a data model doing good things
or bad things to people
what is the likelihood of harm
and and so just internalize that you
know the importance of this and for
those who are wondering this is not my
art it's impossible for me to attribute
it to a human
um I just put in a prompt uh in
mid-journey
um
a Face-Off between
accuracy
and fairness
those who are paying attention half of
these slides are generated by AI
but I'm not an AI I promise
all right
all right because deep learning
applications I've said this once already
I'll repeat our non-deterministic we
biased we need to bias the inputs or the
outputs to get our desired results how
do you define fairness for one solution
will be different for another uh and
human centered practitioners
leverage those comprehensive set of
metrics that you saw that I shared
before to solve this
I'm going to Breeze through uh consumers
and end users
but it's important I was actually going
to cut out this entire section but I
kept it in
you want to avoid over trusting or under
trusting
with the solution after it's integrated
into software your machine learning
model is integrated into software
because people know when they should
people need to know when they should use
the AI without question or whether to
use their own judgment
when dealing with people's lives though
for example with
law enforcement
um
if you under Trust
the
officer you know judge or whoever that's
leveraging the AI will waste time
searching for additional matches for a
perpetrator or what have you
on the extreme
end of that
um
if you over Trust
an ai's prediction the wrong people will
get arrested or even worse killed maybe
when an AI recommendation is wrong
so for the researchers or user
researchers that are hopefully part of
your machine learning team you want to
sort of
calibrate your track trust Factor we
call that calibrated Trust
things are going to explode things are
going to go bad before you serve your
model when you serve your model and
perhaps after
so you have to manage your users
expectations
you want to align feedback with model
Improvement
you want to do these three things
designing mechanisms to request feedback
building functionality to respond to
said feedback
and interpreting implicit
implicit meaning sort of psychographic
analysis of data that you might have
their preferences their likes or
explicit I like this movie
thumbs up five stars what have you
for explicit feedback the user needs
context on the level of con confidence
of a prediction recommendation or
classification whatever decision that
um that the AI is outputting here
leveraging what you've learned from shop
or some explainability tool
could be boiled down and explained like
I'm five to a consumer
I've been told I'm running out of time
so these sorry these are some takeaways
debiasing techniques
um
also benefit non-protected or on
underprivileged classes it's just noise
so consider some of these tools and
techniques
some of these packages
that claim to help you out with
debiasing your data sets suck so
um
aif 360 notoriously has terrible support
I've been Shilling I've been sort of
pushing it but look at larger ecosystems
unfortunately like tensorflow or
Microsoft fairlearn
so I want to end with this
after two years of doing research in
this space this is how I Define fighting
bias with bias it's what was what is and
what should be
for with what was an acknowledgment that
we aren't perfect and left unchecked we
propagate our biases in the models we
train with what is recognition that we
already introduced bias into the process
to improve performance accuracy and
optimizing for error and what should be
uh by that I mean putting these into
practice tooling and approaches that
I've talked about today
um in efforts to solve these constrained
optimization problems as part of your
workflow making it making these hard
trade-offs and hard having these hard
conversations to avoid disproportionate
product failure representational harm or
opportunity uh denial to the groups or
individuals I hope we collectively use
these tools and techniques so that we're
better ancestors uh in this practice so
that my daughters can live a better
have a better lived experience online
with some of these tools that we use
thank you
[Applause]